i'm here with dr lawrence baker from
stanford medical school and we're going
to talk about healthcare costs or
healthcare economics which you're
you're an expert in i like to spend a
lot of time thinking about health
economics and stuff like that yeah so so
all of these charts which all seem to
have a a similar shape here these are
essentially measures of how much we're
spending on on health care so this first
one right here was this total health
spending 1960 to 2009 and this is the
united states this is the united states
this is data that's compiled by the
federal government every year since well
1960 in this figure this is is this
adjusted this isn't adjusted for
inflation that's not adjusted for
anything that's the total dollar value
that the the folks in the federal
government who like to calculate this
number have come up with for the amount
we spend on health care in a year okay
so someone looking just at this data
point might say okay maybe it's not
inflation-adjusted maybe the inflation
curve is also growing up growing at some
rate here but the absolute numbers do
seem to be large you're saying by by
2000 by
2019 i guess it's already well 2009
we're already several years past the
past yeah we're two and a half trillion
dollars just to get people clear what
we're talking about because this is in
billions this is two thousand four
hundred eighty-six billion
so that's that's this 2.4 trillion
dollars and then that's projected to
almost almost double by 2019 that's
right
you know and our gdp is on the order of
15 trillion dollars so it's a
significant chunk of everything that we
produce that's a big chunk of everything
we produce yeah and going up going up
rapidly you know hard to predict a
little bit but all the trends are up and
so we're worried about and this this is
on a per capita basis so i guess there's
there's two ways to think about why
costs are going up
one is is that maybe maybe you just have
a lot more people right and they're
or that on a per person basis you are
spending more right and this chart seems
to imply the latter this says on a per
person basis we're spending more still
not inflation adjusted in this still not
inflation but uh going from a 100 or so
in 1960 to 8 000
in the last couple years and you know
you can see the trend since say 2005 in
there it's up and it's up pretty steeply
right uh just in the last little bit for
maybe 13 or 14 000 14 that's a nice
subcompact car one could one could buy
yeah
not not to say what's more important and
then this is so this next try right over
here is actually that calculation as a
percentage of gdp and to me this is
maybe one of the most relevant things
because that that that that adjusts it
for things no it doesn't directly adjust
for inflation but it says look of as a
percentage of all of the goods and
services as an economy that we're
doing this is a percentage right so this
is this is an interesting one right here
so in 1960 roughly five percent of
everything that all the america all the
goods and services that americans
produced 120 of that of our energies was
spent towards health care right and now
it's looking like it's closely
in the next few years it's going to it's
going to be approaching 20 percent it's
already in the upper teens it's yeah
it's well it's past 15 16 and we're
headed up um you know the last year or
so maybe was a little slow growth but
you can see the trend over the last
decade or two decades it's up up and up
so you're right as we as when health
economists when people in who think
about this uh more deeply want to think
about healthcare spending two and a half
trillion is an interesting number eight
thousands initially but this one
captures population growth to a large
extent captures inflation and the fact
that we're spending a dollar one seventh
roughly of our productive capacity on
healthcare isn't interesting and closely
approaching one actually it's already
one six and approaching one fifth fifth
yeah of of everything that we do is is
about uh healthcare
and and i guess i mean there's a couple
of things there maybe maybe we're
getting healthier i guess there's one
possibility um or maybe we aren't and
then we this is something that's weird
well that's the really interesting
question you know where we think about
why this is going up but at the end of
the day you're happy if it's if we're
spending this much and
we're spending more than other countries
we're spending more than we did last
year if we're getting healthier because
of it or if we're getting happier
interesting question if we want to count
happiness that doesn't make us healthy
but if we're getting something we value
and we're getting worried and we get
worried if we are many forms of
happiness that do not make you healthy i
think that's right though this is
the end of the day this is maybe our
biggest question
some will
act directly against your health but but
uh and that goes that goes that goes
straight into this chart what you're
talking about it's like well you know
maybe maybe we should or maybe we
shouldn't compare ourselves to other
countries and and this is comparing
ourselves to other countries so this
chart right over here this is the blue
graph so we are this light blue i'll do
that same so this is us this is the
united states right over here yep that
is us united states and if we compare to
other developed countries with i guess
not too different to demographics in
terms of overall developed countries
industrialized countries countries where
the standard of living is in pretty good
shape right right and they have they
have a broad you know it's not a
homogeneous not entirely homogeneous so
people will argue we'll say the us is is
more diverse than the united kingdom is
quite it's quite different pretty
diverse countries generally you know
certainly countries with immigration
issues that the us has countries with
lower income and higher income
populations at the uss so they're pretty
diverse right so i mean when you look at
this this is actually maybe this is the
the real chart to look at because this
is this gives you a percentage of gdp
but also puts it in context of other
countries and that's where they're all
kind of bundled around in this you know
i don't know the low end it was this
actually the uk i didn't realize is
actually at the low end as a percentage
of udp all the way at france is at the
high end of gdp
and
yeah so i've done a little picking and
choosing of the european countries here
there are some that are a little higher
but nobody comes close to the u.s right
these are the big ones uk is the lowest
in the world really of the developed
countries the european countries
and
france and germany canada common
competitors to the us at 10 or 11 so
we're uh 50 higher 60 higher than than
those double what
what's going on in the uk and do we know
what why we're doing this or you know
are we getting
i guess where is that going where are we
spending money that these other
countries aren't
right so two places ultimately the
economics of it would say if you're
spending more than somebody else you're
it's about how much stuff you're buying
what kind of things you're buying and
then the price that you're paying right
per thing so we're talking either about
prices or quantities right right right
so it's a little bit of both if you
compare us across countries um we spend
we buy more of some kinds of services
than other countries buy there's um
some interesting comparisons like we
might get more mris per person or
something like we have we certainly do
get more mris per person it's kind of
interesting it's not that we have more
doctors per capita say or more hospital
beds per capita it's not that we get
more primary care visits in the us it's
actually true
in many european countries you get more
primary care visits more time with your
primary care doctor than we get in the
u.s but it's uh you know if you're if
you're picking a poster child it might
be the mri or something more
sophisticated some of the more expensive
specialist visits uh lots of tests and
and things like that that uh we buy in
the united states that you don't buy in
europe and and that drives up our health
care costs it's definitely so we
definitely are buying more and and it's
costing us more per and the price is
also different in the united states and
this is there's some people who've done
studies of this and there's always
little bits of debate about how you
define these prices exactly but right um
you know we pay doctors
and if you're finding doctors annual
incomes they're going to be higher in
the united states that is to say we're
paying some sense a higher price for a
year of work from a doctor than they pay
in europe paying a higher price for our
hospital administration for our staff in
the hospitals and things we're tending
to pay more so we pay we buy more things
we tend to buy more of the more
expensive things right and we tend to
pay a higher price you know roughly how
much of of the healthcare dollar goes
towards
salaries versus drugs versus things like
mris and
kind of fixed costs like like mris and
hospital
and beds and things like that yeah so
some of this you can figure out we we
could almost put another slide up here
on the figure there or in the on the
screen there um
the u.s health accounts will tell you
some things like doctors and hospitals
and drugs drugs you know 10 or 15
percent a little less than that okay i'd
have to go back and look at the data on
the on physicians but you know
physicians
you know let's say
that uh hospitals and physicians are
20 or 30 i i i
it's not 90 it's not 90 we say hospitals
and physicians that so that includes
outpatient and inpatient
yeah you know there's so there's lots of
ways that these health accounts get
broken up um right you know physicians
uh hospitals
emergency departments different kinds of
equipment and things that get purchased
and there's research and there's
buildings and all that kind of so just
physician pay once again none of these
things do make up the bulk of it we had
a video about drug pricing but drug
pricing by itself is not the reason why
we're we're out here and physician pay
by itself is not the reason why we're
out there or even having more
all of these are contributing it seems
like we're
all of these we're getting more of and
we're we're paying for it's it's amazing
at the end of the day it's going to be a
bunch of things like this all thrown
together we buy more stuff we tend to
buy more expensive stuff we buy it from
people who we pay a lot to we buy more
specialist visits for example in the us
we pay specialists a higher annual
salary than we pay generalists and that
comes out in the prices
they don't do that in europe europe does
pay more but everybody's shifted down
all the physicians and are so shifted
down and i think the specialists are
probably shifted down more
in europe than the generalists are
we pay more for our prescription drugs
here we pay more now what are we getting
in in in terms of other than you know
more mercedes in the doctor's parking
lot no i'm kidding i'm kidding no no no
that's although you do see a lot of them
seems to be the car of choice when i
visit the doctor
but but
what what is and i'm not saying that my
wife's a physician and obviously we all
work with many so
they've worked very hard so i'm not
going to i'm not going to say that they
make any statement about their
underpayer overpay uh and especially
relative to some people and you're in
the finance world i would say that
they're definitely underpaid possibly
yes yes yes they're above mercedes
but but and so are we getting anything
in exchange for this are we getting
less wait times are we getting a better
access to our doctors what are we
getting or what do we know about that
well so this is the debate this isn't in
maybe a microcosm one of the big debates
we're having in the us right now we're
spending more every year we're spending
more than other countries if it was
clear we were twice as well off twice as
we're growing faster too and we're
growing faster and we're growing yes it
depends on how you look at the timing
but we're growing a little faster in
some years um you know our healthcare
costs go up 10 if we're if we knew we
were 10 happier this year with our
healthcare system we'd be happy and and
that's the big debate there are some
cases some where the u.s uh you can
there are things you can point to we
have fewer waiting lines for some
services and some of the countries that
keep the costs down have more lines
you know it's not all it's also not the
case that they have waiting lines for
everything and they're really serious
stuff doesn't tend to have long waiting
lines we
get we get easier access to some of the
high-tech stuff which we like and so
that drives up our spending but maybe
makes us happy but it may it may or may
not lead to better out so it makes us
happy that we feel like we're getting
better customer service instead of
waiting three weeks instead of waiting
three months for a procedure we're
getting in three weeks which would make
me happier i mean objectively i would be
much happier about that
um but
what happens when we look at the overall
outcomes that you know life expectancy
and and people dying from heart disease
or you know whatever this is kind of a
mixed bag there are some of the the most
commonly cited figures are cases where
the us doesn't do as well as some
european countries we and usually it's
you know we spend a lot more we don't do
better on life expectancy we don't do
better on infant mortality there are
some cases where the u.s does does
really well especially things where
access to the high-end stuff can make a
difference and so there are some
situations where it looks like we buy
the kinds of things that are really
going to make us healthier but it's not
not across the board and some of the
really interesting ones are cases where
there's fairly inexpensive stuff that
looks like it would work well and and
improve outcomes and sometimes we're not
doing the inexpensive stuff that other
countries are doing and it's coming out
to maybe hurt us in our outdoors so
there's a
you know we wouldn't be having the
debate if it were clear if we were
clearly better off but it's really the
case that in only some of the measures
do we end up better off we don't always
vaccinate our kids more we don't always
get people screened more for cancers and
things like that but um you know
sometimes we do so there are cases that
there are success stories here now one
thing that comes that's interesting
about looking at this chart a little bit
deeper is that it doesn't look like this
is something that you know since the
american revolution that we've been
spending double as a percentage of gdp
relative to everyone else i mean if i
just look at this chart right here it
seems like us in canada we were right
along very similar to each other to
about the early 70s and then but we were
still in kind of that pack with germany
and france i guess for the relatives of
the uk we actually always been have been
higher but then right around i mean
right around this time period there i
don't know late 70s early 80s that's
where we really started to break off
what i mean was there some policy shift
there or so there's not a tangible
specific policy shift what starts
happening in the u.s there is we start
adopting and we start shifting toward
the higher end stuff more and some of
that's the population that's when the
technology started to really get
i think that's mainly the story you know
we started to to really the the research
and things the development that went on
in the in the world really from 1940 50
60 started to produce the capacity to do
new and expensive things and the us
grabbed those and other countries in the
world were
less quick to grab them maybe you could
say more careful maybe say too careful
too slow but the u.s
as you see there really quickly started
to put up specialized hospitals started
to buy the fancy equipment and uh you
know you can see what kind of came out
of it cool and to some degree probably
the whole world benefited from that
because you're you are going back to the
drug pricing or the you know the mri
manufacturers are able to get those
returns and
hopefully much of that they're able to
reinvest and not spend too much on other
things but yeah it is it is fueling yeah
some of the innovation if
you know there's always these kinds of
questions that swirl around here if the
u.s pays a lot of money and that comes
back into innovation that everybody
benefits from including us maybe it's
okay um you know i think there are
people who debate whether we got enough
innovation enough benefits that's
tangibly related to our spending to make
our spending worth it um but there are
some cases where that probably happened
and so you know there's some subtlety to
the question but
yeah i always say if you're the yankees
and you're going to pay the huge amount
for the for the big payroll and the big
uh stars people expect you to win every
time and that's the kind of us's
challenge we're going to pay the big
bucks so we really feel like we want to
show results every time and you know
sometimes we do get the results but it's
not it's not ambiguous it's not
ambiguous we're not winning the
championship every every day
very very interesting